address causes controversy Kanye West
said watch and my man LP stops blogging
I'm Gloria Borger and this is puny Brad
or Brad - what the heck are you doing
you're supposed to edit the lasers so
they come from my fingers instead you
just blast them look all across the
screen what am I even paying you for
hello Brad - its Brad one this boy
thinks we've got time to actually track
the lasers coming out of which of his
individual fingers like we ain't like we
ain't got [ __ ] to do with that day
it'll pass anything on top of that we've
got an hour to edit each of these every
day but he's literally making us into
slaves like this
[Music]
good evening I'm Gloria Borger
your favorite me the most reputable news
source in this entire MIT world our
first story comes from Twitter and my
god is everyone tweeting this at me so
apparently some guy got really mad and
upset that some girl who's not Chinese
wore a Chinese dress to prom and she's
not allowed to do that because that's
called for our prop reaction and Archana
change what I'm not gonna do a racist
Chinese accent for this that would just
be horrible and racist I'm not like
Jeremy just dropping n bombs and other
racists derogatory terms left and right
while calling other people out wait a
minute wait a minute I just don't
understand I just don't understand how
people can use such foul and considerate
disgusting hurtful language I'm just
thinking about everyone getting in
culturally appropriated right now
somewhere you know somewhere somehow
some what someone is wearing something
that they are not allowed to wear and
that's just that's just mean and hurtful
and I I'm glad we have people like
Jeremy Lamb literal Saints calling these
people out Jeremy all tweeted out a
statement after being called out for
thoroughness yes I used to be more
ignorant than I am now my youth was not
perfect it was problematic
what can we all just have a round of
applause for Jeremy I think he's gonna
get a non-perfect everybody all right so
to summarise in case I didn't explain it
well enough
this guy just found this girl on Twitter
and she was wearing a Chinese dress and
he made this tweet and it got a lot of
retweets why this guy thought to take it
upon himself to speak for all Chinese
people or all Chinese women for that
matter it's not like he's worn the dress
and then completely just defending
himself from after being called out just
be honest and say what it is you wanted
retweets online you wanted attention and
you knew exactly how to get it
this whole fabricated social media
outrage is just getting old at this
point I'm sick of it I don't even want
to waste any more time on it let's move
on wow it looks really lame without any
lasers doesn't it
remember everybody don't take what you
have for granted life could always get
worse sorry I forgot to tell you if you
guys want to stop cultural appropriation
and just buy the Hat this who could get
my hat merch
it's got five days left on it before
year before we never sell it again
and we don't ship to Russia so that
means anyone but Russians can wear it
and today in awesome news guys orange
shirt kid finally was made into a
dancing fortnight remember orange shirt
kid
he didn't win the fortnight boogie-down
challenge so he would be made into a
dancing fortnight and everyone got
really mad and he should clearly should
have won this is the best dance I have
ever seen in my life well I got good
news for you it's made into a dance how
great I'm sure he's going to get part of
the revenue of course now this is all
thanks to fabricated social media
outreach that's started by dull and
darker
[Music]
starting the hashtag justice for orange
kid campaign for real I think it's cool
that Epic Games finally listened he
deserved to win it's sort of not funny
anymore
I feel like now it's the meme is dead
and I truly understand how people feel
when I review a meme
I mean when PewDiePie review Shamim on
meme review I get it next news today in
awesome news axe is coming out of every
single console ever in May and today an
awesome news Logan poll stopped daily
vlogging wait a minute are you telling
me someone that he's making less ad
revenue than ever and probably selling
less merch than ever decided to go on
another path of earning revenue I don't
understand this I don't understand it at
all please buy a hat in case you haven't
already
honestly legit I I am making more on
selling these hats this month than I'm
making on ad revenue despite uploading
daily content do you understand how bad
ad revenue I might as well not even call
myself a youtuber I'm a hack merch I'm a
hat salesman at this point that is my
profession and really just I want to
thank YouTube for having such great way
of monetizing on their platform it's
it's wonderful I'm so thankful you
probably notice Kanye West has been
tweeting a lot lately among things what
he tweeted was I love the wait Candice
Owens thinks this got a lot of news
coverage and it became sort of a
controversial statement let's see why
why that is
victim mentality is not cool I don't
know why people like being oppressed so
weirdest thing I've ever heard I love
oppression we're oppressed 400 years of
slavery Jim Crow which by the way none
of you guys live to your grandparents
didn't it's embarrassing that you
utilize you utilize their history you're
not living through anything right now
you're overly privileged American then
following up with self victimization
disease we have freedom of speech but
not freedom of thought now I talked
about a go a few videos back and I
realize now I I was wrong kanya has such
a massive ego and he was so aware of it
that he doesn't back down of what other
people criticizing form which is so rare
these days the fact that everyone just
backs down is what has created this
polarizing climate of ideas where we all
know in a public setting what ideas are
power allowed to be said and what ideas
are just plainly not and a lot of times
common sense is forbidden because it
doesn't fall in the pool of thoughts
that we're allowed to say or allow to
think because they're somewhat
controversial and they they get attached
to all these extremist groups when
really a lot of times we're just talking
common sense obviously con you things
like this because he's a very successful
guy if anything it's nice to see people
staying true to their ideas because
we're too long everyone is bought into
the same sort of mentality I've done
that mistake myself for example here
with the case of the dress I'm glad that
keziah
decided not to delete the the tweet and
be proud of her dress just because this
sparked public outrage doesn't mean that
she thought she was wrong and she might
any my opinion she wasn't next
nice to see you Danny I'm going to take
a nap let's talk about a beachy you guys
probably heard of was it a few weeks ago
a beach she died and it sort of came as
a surprise if you've seen photos of him
near the the death you could tell
something was wrong
Avicii died of apparent suicide he
really struggled with thoughts about
meaning life happiness and he could not
go on any longer he wanted to find peace
this whole story sort of hit a bit too
close home for me with young Swedish guy
I think he was he was my age even from
Sweden he described himself as an
introvert he just had a passion and it
became successful obviously I'm nowhere
near successful as Avicii but it's I
it's it's too similar to me I feel like
you know in another universe this could
have been me I obviously don't know Tim
I never met him it's not really fair on
me to project a bunch of ideas around it
in 2016
Tim Barling had stopped touring because
he had some health issues but he also
said to me it was something I had to do
for my health the scene was not for me
it was not the shows and not the music
it was always the other stuff
surrounding it that never came natural
to me all the other parts of being an
artist I'm more of an introverted person
in general it was always very hard for
me I took on board too much negative
energy I think I can imagine Tim just
wanting to create music he's a
passionate guy that became successful
everything that came with it was just
too much I don't know I'm just
speculating I know it's not really fair
for me to do but I want to be able to
discuss this at least or what I think
about it because a lot of people look at
people that are successful and they just
think how could they commit suicide they
have everything and I'm not saying that
so that I would get some sort of pity or
like oh it's so hard it's really that's
not it at all I'm just saying it for you
guys so you understand that this whole
idea of fetishizing success in a way
that it's the ultimate goal then if you
get popular than
then you then you've required everything
and if you required money then that's
all that matters because it really isn't
and we really need to stop thinking that
way I've talked about happiness a lot on
this channel it's a topic I discussed a
lot because I've seen so many people
struggle with it you youtubers I mean
because I think constantly being
evaluated by numbers as soon as you make
one mistake it will seem like the whole
your whole fanbase I never want us to
turn against you with a tragedy like
this I feel like I want to do something
about it I feel like I can do something
but I don't know what when I filmed
scare PewDiePie I think that was the
worst time for me when I did YouTube
because I felt so trapped doing
something that I didn't really want to
do I was taken away from what I really
wanted to do was wish to make videos but
my network at the time had just put up
so many projects and so many things on
me I was stuck doing things that I
didn't want to do even though I had the
dream laid out for me and as an
introvert a lot of times things that see
me seem attractive and amazing things is
just a chore and and a pain and and it's
not for everyone I realized in a way now
I'm talking about Tim suicide in a way
that for me to talk about my own
problems but I do think they correlate
in a sense I did like I said I don't
know Tim I don't know what he went
through but what from what I can gather
at least I feel like I can at least
understand it to some degree
we're so stuck on this idea that
successful people have everything it
makes it even harder to open up about
these issues I'm just really really
sorry and my thoughts go out to Tim's
family and his friends and his fans that
was it for pew news everybody way to end
it on a high note thank you for leaving
like thumbs this video check out the
merchant all that stuff I'm Gloria
Borger and this is pool news see you see
you next
you don't get an outro you don't deserve
one